has this been an emotional campaign from
from the very beginning I think just
just the fact that just won't after this
have you experienced a lot of emotion
yeah they went after the string it's
been it's been a lot of up and downs I
mean um you know because we knew it was
going to be an uphill battle but we
always told ourselves we just need to
clear that twenty percent if we can
clear that twenty percent before the
last couple of days then anything can
happen and obviously we didn't get to
that twenty percent and you know it's
just it's racking our brains and the tub
thing is it's racking your brains trying
to figure out what's not working while
still while still pushing out the things
that you need to push out um you know
staying staying active and I think there
are a couple there are a couple days
that we lost a stain active just um just
because of um you know the day jobs or
the train I mean one thing that was
tough was about having the broken foot
um made a little challenging um but then
but I had to stay in the boot two weeks
longer than planned which that and that
happened right after you know we made a
really big push in the first week we're
really happy with how the first week
when we got some pickup shots um and
then the plan was supposed to be get
those pickup shots into the edit and um
and I was going to get a boot off that
next day instead I got sick we didn't
get to get any editing done in a violent
had to be in her boot for two more weeks
and that was such a blow and I think
that's one of those cases or our entire
momentum went back to zero and it was
very hard not just did to start up from
that point but to start off from a
really really low point and you don't
get and I think in general where we are
pretty good about you know if he's down
about something then like I'll pick it
up you know it's like okay I'll keep
working on it while at the same time
like splitting my attention between that
and then also saying like you know it's
going to be okay like like this is what
we're going to do and then it's almost
like that energy would then reverse
right so it's like you know it's been so
much time doing that and it's like okay
I'm like no I don't know so I mean I
guess it's it's it's good that we have
that that we can at least you know it's
almost like I can't feel like I don't
have time to feel sorry for myself if
I'm worried about getting it done and
then making sure that he's okay so as
soon as he's okay then okay now I'll
take a minute then i can plug away for a
bed and then check in on her and make
sure that she's I mean it has it has
been sort of very emotional in that way
where I mean there's a lot of self-doubt
it's like you question why you're doing
this and you know there was one moment
where it was in good spirits at this at
this point but I had just said you know
it's like if this works this is just
like one quarter of the battle because
then we still have to shoot it anything
if you have to do post and then
distribute it like there's so many
pieces that requires so much energy and
when you look at that that path in front
of you it's hard to see the light at the
end of the tunnel and then and then you
know wonder like is it worth it do you
want to do it and then and then you ask
yourself those questions but it's like
both but I like it I mean I like doing
it if I'm having fun doing it then okay
so the lights far away but it's there
because I mean it you're not in darkness
if you're having a good time doing it
end and it's enjoyable and it's
something that you're passionate thought
and you love so and I think that's the
one thing that that you know we keep
reminding ourselves that whatever
however the campaign is going or having
fun with it and so long as we're having
fun with it it doesn't matter and you
know the frustration of maybe not
getting where we need to be as far as
money goes has been cancelled out by the
fact that the one we're having fun doing
it and to the support that we've gotten
from people has been awesome and at the
end of the day that's all that really
really matters to us you know maybe we
don't have media reach tip that we want
yet maybe we don't have the vast network
but but we have some really cool people
that absolutely believe in us and that's
what's awesome
you